not all characters are created equal
while kohi hirokoshi
has created some of the most interesting
characters in superhero fiction
there are definitely some bad apples in
the barrel here
are the five best and five worst
characters
in my hero academia all might seems like
a pretty obvious superman pastiche
from his superman-esque powers and
helpful personality
to the color scheme of his costume it's
immediately clear that all might
is meant to stand in for the arguably
greatest superhero
of all time all might even has his
version of the clark kent identity
almight's true form is a spindly
half-starved looking man
named toshinori yagi however horikoshi
takes all might further than just being
a standard homage due to a battle with a
supervillain years before my hero
academia begins
toshinori is limited in the time he can
transform into almight
giving him a clear and obvious weakness
that's
far more easily understood than
kryptonite all might's concerns and
weaknesses are
deeply human he's the world's most
popular superhero and he knows it
striving to live up to his own
reputation is a struggle but
it's important and rewarding enough to
make up for that all mites also just
cool
hands down he's beloved by the world of
my hero academia for a reason
he's strong he's fast he faces down
super villains with a big smile
and a booming voice rather than seeming
godlike and
impossible to relate to all might's
battles and the anime
are some of the most exciting and
nerve-wracking
in the whole show minoru mineta has one
of the worst quirks in my hero academia
but
that's not the character's fault
hirokoshi does a great job
showing that even the most seemingly
useless and absurd quirks have
their own value no what puts minetta on
the worst list
is that he's a horrible little pervert
having an openly perverted character is
a bit of a trope in anime but
just because it's common doesn't mean
it's fun to watch
minetta's obsession with his female
classmates and adult superheroines
is gross past the point of comedy as
much as the anime tries to showcase a
deeper side of the grape-haired hero
by acknowledging his intelligence and
tactical mind his personality is
simply too rotten whatever deeper
thoughts or emotions dwell within mineta
are irrelevant when he acts in such a
lewd
awful way it's no wonder that he's done
so poorly in the popularity pools
before you become a hero you should
learn how to be a good human
when katsuki bakugou was first
introduced he seemed like a pretty
standard antagonist
to zuku midoriya's protagonist he
certainly started out as an aggressive
bully in later rival to uzuku
but as the series has continued it's
become clear that there's more to bakugo
than meets the eye
for starters there's his hero worship of
all might like azuku
he wants to live up to all might's
example as a great hero
but they differ in important ways izuku
admires almighty for his ability to help
while
bakugou admires all might for his
ability to win
once it's made clear how important
constant success and victory is to
bakugou
all of his cruel actions make sense he
was a bully to midoriya because he felt
condescended to
in a way that all might never would be
crucially
my hero academia has shown bakugo's
steady evolution
into a considerate hero in training
while never shying away from his past
behavior as a cruel bully
it's an incredibly thoughtful approach
to a trope that's been handled with
far less care in other anime building a
genuine rivalry and friendship
between two characters who both idolized
the same hero
through his friendships with kiroshima
and todoroki bakugo's revealed a much
more
interesting character lurking underneath
his loud explosive facade
all for one the arch nemesis of all
might and seeming
big bad of the series hasn't revealed
any particularly noteworthy attributes
his quirk which allows him to steal and
combine
other people's quirks is a fairly
standard power set for a final anime
villain
and his character design isn't nearly as
innovative or engaging as other
characters
there's some intrigue to the idea that
he accidentally started the one for all
quirks session
but how he feels about creating his
eternal nemesis or whether he mourns his
brother
haven't really been explored he might
have had a nice looking fight against
all might in season 3 but there haven't
been enough twists
to his character to make him more
interesting in a show that's
consistently surprised viewers
all for one is about as standard as you
can get
while the series is largely about
superheroes there's plenty of screen
time for the villains too
one villain in particular twice has
become one of the most interesting
characters in the show
twice has the power to make a copy of
anything if he knows its exact
measurements
despite the handicork twice is also
completely insane
having cloned himself so many times that
he's unsure whether he's the original or
just clone twice's mental instability
makes him a ticking time bomb for the
heroes
if he ever conquers his fear and really
takes advantage of his power
he'd be nearly unstoppable twice also
shows the less pleasant side of a world
filled with quirks
not every superpower is going to be
beneficial
finally twice offers a different vibe
than most of the league of villains
who are usually somber and moody or over
the top excited
twice minus his quirk and mental issues
is a relatively normal friendly guy
he's just a normal guy who is so
horrified at the existential dread of
possibly being a copy of himself that he
basically
became deadpool i may be a villain but
i'm human
too we all are man
don't be concerned if you don't even
remember mustard
one of the villains who invaded the
training camp in order to kidnap bakugou
while the other league of villains
members get moments to showcase their
unique skills and personalities
mustard is pretty handily defeated by
the also rans of class 1b
his quirk allows him to emit sleeping
gas over a large area but
mustard himself isn't immune to it that
means that he has to wear a gas mask in
order to keep from getting knocked out
by his
own power that's a pretty silly weakness
to begin with but
it gets worse he's so completely punked
by the 1b
students that he hasn't been mentioned
or shown on screen since his defeat
he was only a stepping stone for side
characters to show that they mattered to
the story too
we can't all be winners but mustard
seems like a born loser
at first glance stain seems like an
over-the-top parody of the gritty
anti-heroes that filled the pages of 90s
superhero comics
on a second and third glance that seems
to be consistent
especially when he's enacting brutal
vengeance on heroes that he deems
unworthy of their status
however stan's existence in the world of
my hero academia
allows for a wider perspective of the
ethicality of superheroism
up to this point in the story villains
were simply criminals who wanted to do
evil stain's very specific ethos allows
for the consideration that
villainy in academia has more to do with
frustrations against the status quo
than entirely devious motivations
interestingly
his role in the story also works well
with his visual parody of 90s ninjas
he provides a bloodthirsty alternative
to both heroism
and villainy which leads at least two
impressionable teens to follow his
examples simply because
he's cool that's a hilarious way to
reference the violent examples of 90s
superhero comics without
actually devolving into full-blown
comedy
spinner joined the league of villains
after being inspired by stain and he
considers himself the embodiment of
stain's legacy
hilariously spinner's quirk makes him a
human lizard
while his costume is clearly styled
after stain in a way spinner is a visual
callback to the teenage mutant
ninja turtles who were themselves a
parody of ninja mutant comics like
daredevil and x-men
having stain who's basically a mix of
punisher and daredevil inspires spinner
who's basically a mix of stain and the
teenage mutant ninja turtles is some
pretty funny visual humor however that's
all he really is to the story
even in the villain showcase arc in the
manga spinner doesn't get
any of the same standout character beats
or intriguing power upgrades that his
cohorts in the league of villains do
he's just not interesting enough to land
any higher in the rankings
a racer head has a bit of an edge over
most of the other characters in my hero
academia when it comes to ranking the
best and worst
for starters he's class 1a's homeroom
teacher which means he spends the most
amount of time with the most
important characters giving him plenty
of screen time
for another his quirk which allows him
to shut off other quark users powers
when he's looking at them
is useful without feeling like a cheat
finally he's got one of the coolest
visuals in the series with his goggles
and all black outfit
however there's more to erase her head
than meets the eye
so to speak he's aware of how relatively
weak his quirk is compared to someone
like
almight so he's compensated for it by
training his intellect and body
he's basically the batman of my hero
academia
if instead of constantly brooding and
figuring out how to kill superman
batman used that time to train dozens of
robins
there are a lot of characters in my hero
academia but even the more minor
characters have still gotten to shine
more than oji romashiro
ojiro is a martial arts practitioner
with a quirk that gives him a prehensile
tale
it's not the most exciting quirk but in
fairness ojiro isn't the most exciting
character
his relative plainness has been played
for laughs and
has largely been the only character
detail that he's gotten
there's plenty of possibility in a
character that just works harder than
his more talented
peers but we haven't really seen that in
the anime or the manga
even in a world where anyone can be a
hero it seems like some people are still
just average check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one